[Music]
the 2019 bbm A's were all about BTS the
kpop superstars took the Billboard Music
Awards by storm
first slaying the red carpet in
coordinated dark suits never inspector
like something like this it's like
beyond our dreams the guys were in high
demand all night celebs clamoring to
take pics with the band like cardi B
Drake Madonna Becky G Khalid Terry Crews
and Kumail Nanjiani I know I saw BTS and
freaked out
and during the show they were living
their best lives singing and dancing
along
[Applause]
dreams come true they racked up not one
but two awards top social artist and top
duo or group no this was only possible
because of the little things we share
together the BTS an army power right
does let's keep dreaming the best rooms
together thinking I love you all Wow our
faith army I love you for sure one of
the standout moments of the night BTS
took the stage with Halsey to perform
their new single boy with love
[Music]
[Applause]
et sat down with the musicians in May
2018 where they gushed over the
overwhelming support from their fans
around the world sometimes really feel
like we're getting we're getting like
more love than even we deserve so we
really tried to do all we can do is like
all we can't get it back is that you
know we focus on our you know car graphy
is music that's all we do
[Music]